notre dossier sur lequel on note une
avancée majeure lors de ce g20 les taxes
sur l'acier l'aluminium les états unis
et l'union européenne sont parvenus à
s'accorder washington elle va supprimer
les droits de douane sur les
importations d'acier et d'aluminium donc
de son côté bruxelles n'appliquera pas
certaines mesures de rétorsion prévues
pour entrer en vigueur au 1er décembre
sur des produits comme les motos harley
davidson ou encore le bourbon du
kentucky un accord qui met fin à la
brouille commercial déclenchée par
l'administration trump en 2018 et pour
massimo nava éditorialiste au quotidien
corriere della serra cette 16e édition
du g20 a permis de faire émerger des
compromis malgré lé point de dissension
entre les états membres écoutez c'est un
peu les méthodes merkel dans la
communauté internationale c'est à dire
la recherche de compromis possible et
donc même ce sont des compromis
niveau
capable d'amour
concret et pas encore à concrétiser on
voit que la commune est un resto nal
avance et ça c'est la suivre plus
positive deux devant notamment sur la
taxe lemouchi nationale et souley sous
les bassins
évidemment m la barre assez haut à
70 au sens de fascination pour le film
en b et c c'est très difficile à
réaliser notamment parce que on voit qui
est encore à vis à l'exclusion des
bassins des la russie et l est de la
chine